inside the 9/11 plot and why the FBI and
CIA failed to stop it as we approach an
anniversary which we all wish we did not
have a need to commemorate this book
brings us inside the workings of our
government and terrorist agencies it is
an attempt to explain why the events of
what we refer to as 9/11 occurred it is
not a condemnation of individual
officers or agents but rather the story
of why the isolation policies and
jealousies of various government
agencies failed to recognize that
terrorism was bound to hit our shores an
Emmy award-winning journalist John
Miller reports for ABC formerly he
reported for NBC and he also served as
deputy police commissioner of the New
York City Police Department for public
affairs please welcome him thanks very
much thank you very much for coming and
I'm gonna talk a little bit about the
book the cell tonight I'm gonna try not
to talk about it too much because I
don't want to spoil the end for those of
you who bought it and I want to leave
time for questions so first let me just
give a few words about my background
which has a lot to do with how I got
here and and probably why I'm talking to
you my father was a reporter and I ended
up following him in into this career
although not from the usual route he was
a reporter for a venerable New York
newspaper called the New York Inquirer
it later went on to be the national
enquirer some of you may be familiar
with it and he taught me the rules of
journalism easy it took me a great deal
of time to unlearn them the way it
worked was when I was probably seven
eight and nine
he decided that I was old enough to go
with him on his rounds he wrote seven
different columns under six different
names one of them being John J Miller
the other being John J R Elam which was
Miller spelled backwards those were for
the scandalous items he wasn't exactly
sure about I think he was Sergio someone
from Rome and Pierre someone from Paris
and Nigel someone from London and then
there was his Hollywood identity which I
just can't remember and his rounds
consisted of going to the Copa the El
Morocco the Rat Fink Club the living
room all of the hot spots that the Rat
Pack would have been at in New York and
my idea of a really cool Sunday night
was catching the early show at the Copa
seeing Shecky Greene and then Dean
Martin and maybe if we got really lucky
he'd turn on the police radio in the car
on the way home and we could catch a
homicide before bed this is what
propelled me in a light towards a life
of crime for at least covering it I got
lucky my father's friends from the cope
of course were all guys named Tony to
Arms and Angelo one arm and aside from
the fact that their nicknames that I
knew was their last names all stem from
either food groups body parts or animals
Harry the dog Louie cheesecake they were
a charming bunch who I later ended up
covering and incurring the wrath of only
to find out guys and perp walks were
saying you don't remember me I gave you
a firetruck when you was six so it was
an interesting development the way the
way I came towards this business was I
got a job at Channel 5 News at night
going for coffee and bringing up a film
from the lab I still have to explain to
my interns that yes there was a time
when we actually shot on film
there was a lab because it had to be
developed but one day I called in in the
middle of the night and they mixed me up
on the telephone with somebody else and
they put all the phones on hold and when
they picked up the one that they thought
was a guy named Andy Wilson the veteran
award-winning radio reporter they
explained that they had no reporters
that there was a big disaster in Queens
and what I please respond to the scene
and cover it for television so being in
the ninth grade from New Jersey and it
being it being a Sunday and a school
night I told my father that we really
had to rush to the scene and and get
this done in a hurry so I could get back
home because I had homework so I covered
the story and brought the film back to
the desk of the anchorman Steve Bauman
who had been the guy answering the
phones because they were very
short-staffed on Sunday night this was
Channel 5 News you guys know what is Fox
we knew it is Metromedia it was the 10
o'clock news and we didn't have the
network budget they say when the story
called for a helicopter at channel 5 we
stood on a chair so getting back with um
the film I put it on the anchor man's
desk and this was of no great
consequence to him he was used to seeing
me bring up film he said where's the guy
who covered this for television it's our
lead story I said that was me on the
phone you assigned me he said who the
hell are you
I said I'm in the ninth grade in New
Jersey I work after school two dollars
an hour three days a week anyway
on Monday there was a small inquest to
determine how it came to pass that a
high school freshman covered the lead
story on Sunday's 10 o'clock news and
they essentially said if he could find
his way to Bayside and back and bring
the film in and have the interviews then
what the heck when we run out of people
we can use him so I got to work nights
which was crime now 20 years later I was
minding my own business
sitting in Kampen Yola in Manhattan and
attempting to have a bra Joel I don't
know if you know what a bra Joel is it's
a little kind of tenderloin a port
rolled up tied together with string and
it marinated in tomato sauce herbs and
spices some pine nuts it came with a
little rigatoni some sausage which I
thought was overkill and a couple of
undersized meatballs is like a garnish
so while I was planning for next day's
Lipitor fest and considering this meal
the beeper goes off and they tell us
there's a cop shot then they say there's
a rabbi shot then they say the incidents
are connected they're both at the
Marriott hotel and everybody else at the
table was assigned to Manhattan homicide
I had already been covering crime for
twenty years at that point most
reporters of course had started out in
crime and then like everybody else moved
up into the more important beats I was a
case of terrible Arrested Development
but getting to the scene that night I
found myself in the middle of the murder
of a man I had just had lunch with a
couple of months before Rob rabbi meir
Kahana and rabbi cahana had started the
jewish defense league which was a
radical right-wing jewish group that
took direct action against groups and
individuals that that he thought were
enemies and they had a string of
bombings targeting the russians for
their oppression of Soviet Jewry
they had a string of bombings targeting
different
missions and businessmen they even blew
up and caused a death
the office of salty rock who was a
concert promoter who promoted the
Russian ballet so it was a very busy
group that had been under the
surveillance on and off of the FBI NYPD
joint terrorist task force the JTTF the
group that is probably the driving force
behind the detective story in this book
the cell and kahani died shortly after
being shot while making a speech at the
Marriott hotel at 49th and Lexington was
raised to Bellevue Hospital in to the
emergency room with him comes the gunman
who was confronted by a police officer
for the postal service named Carlos
Acosta who dispatched him Express Mail
right there on the street and when they
engaged in a shootout while Nocera was
trying to apparently carjack a taxi that
night after leaving Bellevue I went to
New Jersey to know Sara's house and
learn from detectives that when they got
there they had run into two men and the
two men were both taxi drivers and the
detectives quickly began to think why
would a well planned assassination
carried out by a guy and with him trying
to hop a cab in Manhattan and make a
getaway
so they began to think he probably
jumped in the wrong cab so they took
these two guys in because they both
admitted to having been around 49th in
Lexington an hour before and the next
day the Chief of Detectives said can you
tell us to the squad commander that this
was the work of one man and he said
can't tell you that we're holding two
other suspects
we found 16 box loads of papers in his
house including drawings of landmarks in
New York City diagrams of prominent
places Rockefeller Center Times Square
the Statue of Liberty the World Trade
Center and so on and and we also want to
look at these two guys in their
background a little further before we
decide whether to make an arrest and he
said that conspiracy stuff is for
somebody else we have a homicide we have
an arrest we don't want to alarm the
public you shut up they'll handle the
conspiracy and release those two guys
now those two guys
went on to blow up the World Trade
Center with a few other people they also
turned out to be his accomplices in the
murder of rabbi cahana but what happened
that night was the beginning of two
important things maybe three one that
night in Manhattan on November 5th 1990
right here in New York City the first
Islamic terrorism cell was born and had
gone to work no Sarah and his friends
had pulled their first job taking their
first direct action against the United
States or at least on the United States
against a target which happened to be
rabbi kahani who might have been an
Israeli target he had been a member of
the Knesset at one point he was the
leader of a political party there the
other thing that happened was the
American law enforcement establishment
on the ground level did its job
they caught the gunman in a gun battle
through terrific heroism chasing down
leads they found two possible
accomplices doing thorough work in
executing a search warrant they found a
trail of leads that would lead them on
to a series of other plots and of course
the third thread that started to stretch
that night was the institutional
bureaucratic pattern for denial the idea
that there were certain things that were
just too messy things the government
didn't seem to want to know because that
investigation as much as it was starting
to take off was derailed and shut down
and I guess in a question and answer
period somebody's gonna ask why but
we'll save that for the Q&A
I'm always hard-pressed to come up with
an answer for that one cuz it doesn't
sound like it makes sense now I worked
in the police department for a little
while and met all the parties involved
and I can probably explain to the
political thinking at the time but to
move forward with the story what then
happens is the joint terrorist task
force guys get together and they say
well if there is a conspiracy and it's
gonna be we who have to uncover it and
what do we have here they were trailing
a group of african-american Muslims in
Brooklyn connected to some radical
mosques who were suspected of robbing
banks but they weren't looking at that
as terrorism per se they were looking at
as a strictly criminal case
there were terry tailing a group of
Egyptian men connected to the same
mosque who were doing all kinds of
military training and target practice
with long rifles at firing ranges
strangely and some of their
surveillances the years later as they
compared the photographs they saw their
two groups were coming together
cross-training sometimes
meeting exchanging messages the full
import of that didn't come together for
a while
what did come together is that both of
these groups were acting with increasing
violence or propensity towards violence
the one group had hired a man who
luckily turned out to be an informant of
the JTTF and that group wanted commando
training they wanted to know how to
scale walls and rappel from buildings
they wanted to know how to do fast
tactical stops of cars and pulled people
out very quickly they wanted firearms
training and whatever it was that they
were looking to do and they didn't let
on what their intended purpose was it
screamed violence to the task force the
other thing that was going on with the
other group was that they were
penetrated by a second informant a man
named Ahmad Salem and he was reporting
back to the FBI that they were talking
about a series of bombings to carry on
for Nosair who was now in jail as a
footnote Nosair who committed the Conny
murder in front of a room as crowded as
this one and in front of this many
witnesses was acquitted of the murder
and convicted of the gun charges and of
shooting at the police officer in a very
strange trial but we'll get back to that
it's just another one of the things when
you look back on this case and say how
did we get where we are today well
that's one of the reasons we got there
they were visiting Nosair in jail and he
had essentially two plots the 12 Jewish
locations plot the bombing plot and then
a more self-serving plot which was break
me out of jail now if you looked at the
one group straining repelling from walls
pulling people out of vehicles doing
fast pays tactical
that sounds like it could be a jailbreak
to me call me paranoid the other groups
intent was much more plain which was to
gather the materials make devices and
select targets that were connected to
Jews in New York
the FBI hierarchy in New York did two
strange things at this point number one
because the informant in the case where
they were looking for the commando
training had begun to set up the
meetings to give them the training and
give them some of the equipment although
not weapons some of the tactical
equipment somebody in the FBI decided we
have to shut this down it's too risky
what if two years from now they use this
training in some direct action here or
somewhere else and the newspapers find
out and the story is FBI trained
terrorist group that's not gonna look
good so they shut that down the more
remarkable thing in studies of
risk-averse management decisions was
that because emod celeb the informant
who had penetrated the nosair cell which
at that point was under the inspiration
and leadership of the blind Sheikh Omar
Abdel Rahman who was preaching at the
mosque that these men frequented they
decided because that informant was
afraid to wear a tape recorder he knew
the minute he put on a tape recorder
he'd be he'd have to testify in court
that it was he who made the tapes and
he'd have to tell the rest of the story
he said I'm willing to give you all the
information every day about what these
guys are up to but I'm not gonna lose my
identity by this case because I'll never
be able to work again as an informant or
within the Arab community or anywhere
else so the FBI decided to fire him now
they had effectively lost their eyes and
ears and to the commando plot and into
the plot to set off 12 bombs in New York
City they have to wonder how it is that
they could have cut off their eyes and
ears into either plot but particularly
when targets who were already connected
to a politically connected motivated
murder we're talking about blowing up 12
locations how could they say we only
have one particular source of real-time
in four
in there and we're gonna fire him now
because he won't play by all of our
rules but they did I'm sure we'll get to
that in the Q&A also so that being the
case the FBI tried to play the edges of
it the joint terrorist task force
investigators were very frustrated they
wanted to go forward with both cases
management said no there were reasons
for that which I think I've covered some
of but still they were frustrated
because they didn't know what was gonna
happen next on of course February of
1993 they got their answer there was a
massive explosion in the World Trade
Center six people were killed over a
thousand were injured there were
billions of dollars in property damage
and lost business and now far beyond the
murder of rabbi cahana terrorists had
struck again but in this way a in a way
that resonated not just in New York City
or even around the country but around
the world quickly two things were done
number one Iman Salim the informant who
had penetrated that particular cell of
people was reira crew 'td unfired and
put back to work in short order he
learned that the remaining followers of
the Sheikh as the FBI tracked the
Bombers down around the world working
with New York City detectives who found
one in Egypt who found another later in
Pakistan who tracked their master bomb
maker Ramsay Yosef literally around the
world till they caught him in a
guesthouse one day outside of Karachi
the terrorist task force sent Sal em
back to work and he found out that the
new plan among the sheiks followers who
included most of the people that they
had started to see in the plot to get
the commando training well it turns out
that my guess was wrong the commando
training didn't seem to be for a
jailbreak when they got the diagrams and
they looked at the street names and and
and it was sixth Avenue in the 50s and
they figured out what the pictures were
off it was to have an assault an
assassin a
you know gyptian President Hosni Mubarak
during his visit to New York while he
was at the Hilton Hotel on Avenue of the
Americas they warned Mubarak not to come
because they they couldn't stop the plot
in time or at least be sure that they
would they canceled that trip the rest
of the plan was to blow up the Holland
Tunnel the Lincoln Tunnel the George
Washington Bridge the United Nations and
this part they actually took a little
personally the FBI building they rented
them a safehouse emod celeb the
informant who was the fired informant
was now rehired had convinced them that
he was an expert bomb maker Tommie
Corrigan from the terrorist task force
tells us in the book the cell I'm not
I'm not sure Ahmad celeb could have
brewed a cup of coffee but he played a
pretty good bomb maker so he has them in
there stirring the chemicals to make
these bombs to blow up the bridges and
tunnels the FBI of course has rented the
safehouse for them and has applied it
with video and audio coverage so they
can actually watch this witch's brew
being cooked up and just before the plot
was to take off the bomber started to go
to other sources looking for equipment
and detonators and somebody wisely
figured out well we know that parts of
we gave them won't work but what did
they get some parts that do so they
raided their own safehouse and arrested
everybody and a dramatic takedown there
really forestalled the all-out attack on
New York City now the embassy I mean the
the World Trade Center bombers that went
to trial they were all convicted they
all received sentences in the telephone
number digits most of them received life
the plotters including the blind Sheikh
who allegedly inspired them receive
similar sentences in the plot to blow of
New York and through all the evidence in
those cases they began to find a name
that kept coming up first just a little
bit and then more often name was Osama
bin Laden it turns out that Osama bin
Laden was the man who was paying for the
monthly expenses of the blind Sheikh to
stay here in America it turns out that
Osama bin Laden was the man who funded
the
Afghan Services office which was
downstairs in the same mosque on
Atlantic Avenue in Brooklyn
it turns out that the Afghan Services
office was connected to an outfit called
the services offices in Peshawar
Pakistan which later morphed into an
organization that changed its name to
al-qaeda in slow motion the joint
terrorist task force and and the small
group of us that covered organized
terrorism in America were watching
al-qaeda be born although most of us
didn't know it at that time but as Bin
Ladin's name kept creeping up after the
trial involving the attempt to blow up
the landmarks the FBI joint terrorist
task force agents went down to the CIA
and they said we have a little evidence
here and you probably have a lot of
information do you mind if we flip
through your files and the CIA really
didn't do much business with the FBI and
terrorism back then but this was opening
a new door it was a test of a new
relationship and they said sure take a
look at these files and they found out
that the CIA had volumes of intelligence
on bin Laden on his activities in his
bases in the Sudan of the things he did
in Afghanistan during the war against
the Russians and some of this
information started to connect with
information they had out of all the
names they pick one particular felon
they said this guy was bin Laden's
right-hand man his personal secretary
his aide-de-camp and if we were gonna
capture anybody and flip them who could
kind of opened the doors for us to this
organization al Qaeda it might be this
guy his name was wadi el Hadj he had
been transferred from bin Laden's
headquarters to an outpost in Nairobi
Kenya where he was running a front an
al-qaeda front which masqueraded as a
charity service for refugees so with the
Kenyan police the CIA and one FBI agent
raided El Hodges house and they took his
laptop and they found a long memo about
the East African cell about how the
engineers I think you can read that as a
codename for bombers were worried that
they would be stopped before they
followed their leaders orders and
essentially was a couple of pages that
was in in fairly plain language saying
that there were plots in East Africa by
these cells that they were working for
Bin Ladin and that they were worried
that the FBI the CIA and the Kenyans
were on to them and of course they were
right
what DL Hodge was convinced that it was
no longer safe for him there he came
back to the United States and settled in
Texas himself a job in a tire store was
called to the grand jury to testify said
he didn't really know Bin Ladin didn't
really know any of these other guys
didn't have any knowledge about
terrorism and the feeling was that
whatever that cell had been up to they
had certainly disrupted it by taking out
their leader and pretty much
transmitting to them that we were on to
you now at this particular moment
something interesting happens we're
trying to find bin Laden because I know
he's now the focus of this investigation
and after months of asking he suddenly
says yes he'll see us
myself and a small team from ABC News go
there we interview him and probably the
strangest interview I've ever conducted
in my career
they said he will answer any of your
questions which I thought was great and
very open and kind of democratic way of
having a discourse they said but we will
not translate his answers and I said
well that won't really work because then
it's gonna be very difficult to have the
follow-up questions and they said that
will be no problem
there will be no follow-up questions now
I was beginning to realize there was a
level of media sophistication here we
hadn't been driven around in the back of
a blacked-out truck for two days for
nothing so during the interview I asked
my 20 questions which I would read from
my paper and then the translator would
repeat and bin Laden had a habit of
looking at the translator because he
knew I had no idea what he was saying
but I had a habit of looking back at him
and nodding as if suddenly miraculously
I had understood Arabic perfectly
that was just to address a television
problem which is I couldn't have an
hour-long interview with a guy looking
over here I need him to be focused in
the direction of the camera so he'd be
speaking to the audience in the end I
went to my translator was kept way in
the back and I said did he actually
answer any of these questions and he
said boss we have a very big story as it
was a story he said he declared war on
America he said he would send Americans
back home and coffins and in boxes and
that the war would start very soon I
said when he was saying this what was I
doing he said you were nodding an
agreement the whole time it wasn't your
normal interview and of course we came
back and broadcast that to the world on
World News Tonight with Peter Jennings
on Nightline for a full half-hour with a
military and national security analysis
by my colleague John McWethy
and essentially America a had met a new
character and B had been put on notice
that he might be very dangerous to this
country and America's reaction was a
logical one which was to lock down all
of its embassies and bases in Saudi
Arabia where bin Laden was from in and
around other Middle East countries where
they felt vulnerable but then the East
African cell which they thought they had
disrupted came back together with wadi
al Hodges deputy who simply took over
operations and simultaneously in August
of 1998 six and a half weeks after my
meeting with Bin Ladin blew up two
United States embassies killing 224
people among them 12 Americans at this
point it was clear that bin Laden had
declared war on America in earnest
it was not clear necessarily that
America was willing to declare war back
75 cruise missiles worth 1 million
dollars apiece were sent towards bin
Laden's three camps one of which we had
this meeting in fairly well destroying
them and based on the intelligence that
bin Laden and his commanders would be
meeting there that intelligence turned
out to be a little off the mark in terms
of timing none of Bin Ladin or his top
aide
were injured but Bin Ladin said in a
communication to us at ABC through our
men in Peshawar the next day that he was
alive and well and that the war had just
begun
the big debate that I think that is
going on in the discourse before
September 11th I'm not gonna spend a lot
of time on September 11th because
there's not a lot that we could talk
about that you all haven't read or heard
somewhere else there are some of the
intimate secrets of the cell that you
can read in this book but as far as the
history of it I think we know that
because it's much fresher than the stuff
I'm talking about now but in the wake of
that that's where Michael Stone and I
and Chris Mitchell who put this book
together tried to stand back and do a
little analysis meaning well why didn't
America declare war back and the answers
and theories are several fold one is
that President Clinton was deeply
immersed in the Monica Lewinsky scandal
which had to be terribly distracting to
day-to-day operations the day that the
day that the missile launch happened was
the day that she was testifying in the
grand jury it's not to say that he
wasn't focused on the response but it
was hard to put your total focus on any
one issue when your presidency was in
jeopardy in jeopardy
I think another issue is sandy Berger
told Michael and I in a meeting who was
the president's national security
adviser yeah it sounds like a great idea
now after September 11th after 28
hundred plus homicides after the largest
terrorist attack in the history of the
world but show me one commentator show
me one congressman show me one senator
show me one reporter who would have said
after 12 Americans were killed in the
embassy bombings that we should have
risked thousands of Americans lives and
invaded Afghanistan think of that in the
context of the post-vietnam American
thinking about wars and invasions in
far-off places who would have who would
have what poll would have told us that
we should have done that I don't know
who did a poll so I don't know if he's
right but it's food for thought and then
of course come September 11th
I'm the history which I don't have to
get into but I wanted to give you a
taste
not of the intimates detective story
that the book is because when you read
the book what you'll do is you'll follow
detectives like Tommy Corrigan who are
involved in the commando training plot
you'll meet detectives like Louie Napoli
who's told to fire his key informant in
the bombing plot you will trail them as
they conduct the most intimate
surveillances of picking up subjects
whose name they don't even know because
they turn up in a surveillance of a
suspected terrorists location and they
trail him and he ends up meeting
somebody and then back of the year at
the office of the task force they
compare photographs and find out that
that guy's in a picture that they took
three years ago of a group they
suspected that was involved in target
practice and how they put together who
they are and how they uncovered all
these plots because an awful lot of
focus and I have to admit a lot of the
focus of this book is what went wrong
what they missed how did they let two of
the September 11th hijackers into this
country free and clear through
immigration and customs 17 months after
the CIA could have put them on a
terrorist watch list because they
recorded them in a secret al Qaeda
meeting in Malaysia it raises all those
questions it attempts to answer some of
them but it also concentrates on some of
the great successes the incredible
detective work in Street savviness of
the New York detectives on the terrorist
task force and they're FBI partners the
plots that were prevented like the the
bombings of the tunnels and the
assassination of the attempted
assassination of Mubarak so it's it's a
it's a book that we had to talk about a
lot because I said to Michael you know
these guys I know these guys a lot of
these guys are our friends and early on
we decided they had done a lot of good
work there had been some missteps and we
would just tell the story flat-out
I'd like to start taking your questions
about about the story and anything else
you wanted to ask about right about now
yes questions first of all about since I
have read your book about celebs
loyalties back and forth second
what light you shed on the Soudan offer
early for bin Laden and then perhaps
something about the bombing of the coal
in order
the trouble with celeb and the FBI brass
even though his agent handlers had faith
in him was that they were suspicious
because he wouldn't wear a tape recorder
maybe his targets really weren't saying
what he claimed they were they say he
would go to meetings and he would go in
and he would come out and he would leave
and that they would watch the building
and the people he said he met with
wouldn't come out they had started to
doubt him which is why they eventually
let him go it was just terrible that the
proof that made him take him back was
such a catastrophic event or that they
didn't really go with the instincts of
the agents who would have continued him
because they knew he may not have been
the easiest informant to work with but
at the time it was their only source of
information the offer from the Sudan
that our questioner refers to is at one
point when bin Laden's bases were in
Sudan the government of Sudan came to
the United States and to shortcut it
they said we don't want to be a
terrorist nation that's on the outs with
everybody and that's the list you've got
us on what do we have to do to get off
the list
and the United States gave them a short
list and one of the things was tell us
all about this guy Bin Ladin and hand
him over to somebody and the Sudanese
approached a couple of countries that
were friendly to us who said yeah we
don't really want him and the Sudanese
said well we'll give him to you so the
United States State Department and CIA
called the Justice Department and they
said if they give us this guy bin Laden
do we have enough to charge him with
something to bring him to trial and they
said well we're working on something but
no not yet so essentially they came to
the Sudanese and said he's organized and
he's operating in your place we can't
take him because we don't know how we're
a constitution we can't just pick up
some guy from a foreign country and keep
him because we feel like it because we
don't like him and we don't have the
evidence sufficient to sustain a
conviction in court yet we may someday
so at least get him out of the Sudan
where he's got his infrastructure and of
course they sent him to the one place
where we could never actually
as any control of them Afghanistan last
part of your question see they thought I
wasn't paying attention I remembered all
this the bombing of the coal as much as
I believe and there's still debate on
this that's my opinion not as a reporter
because that's where I deal in facts but
just as an analyst as much as I believe
the Lewinsky matter distracted the
Clinton administration from putting its
full interest in starting the war on
terrorism the call came at another
difficult political juncture remember
bin Laden had declared war in this
country was almost like he couldn't get
us to declare war back he had bombed two
of our embassies had killed a dozen of
our people and a couple of hundred more
many of them Muslims which was you know
just a an added part of the tragedy and
now he had attacked a warship using a
rowboat and almost taken a billion
dollar piece of America's most serious
Arsenal and sunk it in aden Harbor in
Yemen at that time President Clinton was
desperately fighting for a Mideast peace
accord one probably because it was just
the very right thing to do still is to
probably because as a president whose
legacy had been so damaged by being
impeached by being immersed in a sex
scandal by by having his other
accomplishments so distracted by the
blinding light of that story that I
think he was trying to in a desperate
battle against the clock to make his
legacy something other than that not the
president was caught in a sex scandal
the president left with a Metis peace
deal that stuck now these guys blow up
the USS Cole a seventeen US servicemen
and women who are dead there's 40
some-odd injured a billion-dollar
battleship is about to sink in Aden
Harbor and at this most critical
juncture where they are reaching out for
King Hussein of Jordan to come in and
try and push the parties into a deal
that they're reluctant to make was not
the time that the administration
probably felt it was politically
advantageous to send 74 more
cruise missiles towards bin Laden spaces
in Afghanistan in Islamic country so the
crime of the USS Cole even unlike the
embassy bombings you know where there
was some answer essentially went
unanswered by the United States now to
be fair the Clinton administration said
we went to the Justice Department and
the CIA every day and said do you have
the kind of proof that will justify us
doing something like that I forget bin
Laden and every day they told us no I
think that that's while they were still
operating in a different mindset than we
operate in today back then we considered
everything based on the parameters we
understand as a country for evidence
that could be used in court will it rise
beyond a reasonable doubt now we're much
more in a wartime footing which is if we
think it's more likely than not the
country seems to be willing to take
action abroad I hope that answered those
yes sir
I made a very profound comment on one of
the television programs last Sunday he
said that the moment you heard about the
attack on the World Trade Center that
you knew was bin Laden and I'm sure that
I I came to the conclusion that as soon
as the tech occurred our government came
out and said it was bin Laden also so
they came to the same conclusion and the
conclusion that drew at that point in
time was that they obviously knew about
it for knew something was coming and
personally I find that very disturbing
and do you think the rest of American
but the rest of the world realizes how
disturbing that is I think that the
American government did realize
something was coming I base that on my
discussions leading up to September 11th
with everybody in the intelligence
business and the counterterrorism
business that I was talking to said you
know we can hear the beat of the drums
something is coming
and they were trying like hell to stop
it they broke up the al-qaeda cell in
Frankfurt they broke up that led them to
break up the al-qaeda cell in Milan
Clues found there and in Frankfurt led
them to identify and break up the
al-qaeda cell in London and I said near
the end of August standing in my
backyard at a barbeque to one of my good
friends and invited guest John O'Neill
who was head of the National Security
Division in the FBI's New York office
and the head of the FBI's effort against
bin Laden from the joint terrorist task
force on down I said you guys are doing
great
you got the cells in Europe you foiled a
bunch of plots probably one probably
involving nerve gas the others involving
bombings and attacks you know since
since the Embassy bombing since you've
really put the focus on that with our
worldwide partners they can't seem to
get an attack off the court rasam at the
border who wanted to blow up Los Angeles
Airport on New Year's Day a day before
that there was to be an attack in Jordan
targeting Westerners that Jordan and
intelligence folded that up at the same
time the precursor to the Cole bombing
the attempt to bomb the USS Sullivan's
was underway and you know through
through our lock in their failing the
terrorist took their bomb loaded to the
hilt in a boat the boat had the
explosives loaded in its lining we're
styrofoam and other things that would
have kept it afloat were and they put it
in the water and it sank like a rock I
had to take that back to the drawing
board
so yeah the people who studied us on a
daily basis knew something was happening
and I said to O'Neill they can't they
can't get one off you're just all over
them and he said yeah we're all over
them we got those cells but we don't
know about the one we don't know about
and they didn't know that the one they
didn't know about was the one in
Frankfurt now there were some missed
signals their which are detailed in the
book which in hindsight are pretty
appalling
when you listen to them explain how they
could have been missed why they were
missed some of the answers make sense
some
than others but it wasn't for the lack
of trying but I think they certainly
knew that that the game was afoot and
bin Laden was getting more frustrated by
each time an attack was prevented
let's try somebody right back there yeah
I was I was wondering uh so some of the
facts about the terrorists and their
actions seem to seem to show them in the
light of being bumbling fumbling you
know bumbling fools like like there when
when the economy assassin is supposed to
meet his cab driver and they're not
there or in the 93 bombing when the guy
goes to return the van to the rental
agency and and then there are other
other facts that are coming out about
the terrorists seem to paint them as
very very sophisticated like they did
when the terrorist attack person after
stumble Levant it was there there were
word sleepers we heard about we heard
about terrorists that were that seem to
live among us for many many years you
know very disciplined very sophisticated
and I was just wondering do you see them
as you know just bumbling idiots to get
lucky or or are they are they really are
they really very sophisticated very
smart terrorists I think you answered
your own question I mean when you look
back at mohammed salameh who goes back
to the rental agency where he rented the
bomb that carried the truck to the World
Trade Center and he tries to get his
$400 deposit back on the list of you
know maybe things you'd put don't next
to and your next terrorist plot that's
probably high I doubt in any truck
bombing they have ever gone back for a
deposit since on the other hand you take
a look at the 9/11 plot in stark
contrast look what they did they
committed the largest act of terrorism
in world history they murdered almost
3,000 people in cold blood and
coordinated actions on a single day in a
single country against the targets that
would most symbolize
America's physical might to Pentagon its
economic prowess through the world the
World Trade Center symbolizing business
and finance and commerce in doing so
they shock the sensibilities of
Americans made them afraid in their own
country made them doubt the power of
their own government injured their
economy caused stock prices to fall and
what did they do this with they didn't
have a nuclear weapon although they were
working on it they didn't use chemical
or biological weapons made in a
sophisticated lab although they had one
near the condo our airport they didn't
use a terribly sophisticated plan by
hijacking an f-15 from some friendly
nations Air Force they did this through
meticulous thought and planning by using
box cutters and plane tickets and that
is a formidable enemy which shows
formidable thinking and that's what
we're in danger of now because every
time we have an attack whether it's a
truck bombing or an airplane hijacking
or using planes as missiles we approach
that target we put walls around our
embassies harden the target no truck can
get through we increase airport security
threefold and then tenfold be very
difficult to hijack a plane these days
first of all security should catch you
but we know it's imperfect now what we
know is the passengers will beat the
heck out of you there's no more of that
docile stuff going on that went out
before after September 11th now if you
get up to go to the men's room on one of
these flights four people attack you
right in the aisle the whole different
place now but I mean you have to look at
that's the type of opponent we're
dealing with there well-financed was
probably a plot that cost about a
million dollars or maybe half that on a
shoestring but they still have the
financing and they did the planning that
person in the back with the glasses I my
heart is breaking because if you knew
John O'Neill why wouldn't you connect
that there was some kind of impropriety
that an FBI counterintelligence
superior would be in the World Trade
Center why shouldn't there be term
limits like you could not get a civil
job after if in a certain time span and
what about all those breaches that
Andrea Mitchell confessed to and why
were all the doors of the World Trade
Center stairwells locked this was a
conspiracy led by Dick Cheney mr. and
you better get all of the whole story
so that you have a better picture of
what's really going on it's the foreign
policy mr. Clark has the International
Action Center he can fill you in on why
this is happening to America if that was
a question and I don't I don't mean to
treat it lightly I know I know some
people laughs I'll take a run at
answering it the doors in the stairwell
of the World Trade Center weren't locked
although the doors leading to the roof
were they were locked probably growing
out of a dispute from the last World
Trade Center bombing where the police
department wanted to land their
helicopter on the roof to make rescues
and the fire department objected to that
practice and in some conference with the
Port Authority they had decided to lock
those doors by computer there was a
control center that could remotely
unlock them but by the time the fire had
burned out most of the wires that
Control Center wasn't going to be
reaching anything that answered to
electricity on the roof of those
buildings as far as John O'Neil and you
you know we touch a bit of a nerve here
he was one of the key intelligence
officials of the FBI who in his own
frustration with what was happening with
the bureau and some of the things that
were going on in his career quit the FBI
a couple of weeks after we had that
conversation in my backyard and accepted
a new position that he was very happy
about he was excited to finally be going
into the private sector where for the
first time in his life as a career civil
servant he'd be earning the kind of
money that an executive who didn't work
in government would get he was appointed
director of security for the World Trade
Center and ended up dying on the second
day at work
as far as the rest of those conspiracies
I'm just a New York crime reporter and I
think what mr. Cheney had to do with all
that is a little beyond me tonight but
it's nothing that I wouldn't look into
yeah sorry I know you had your hand up
before I'm trying to catch up oh you
have to start over again he does my
question is about religion when you
listen to bin Laden every second word is
punctuated by Allah knows and now on you
and Allah will know and I it's like a
valley girl when okay it's one way of
looking at it probably not his view but
I got the analogy my question is you
know we've talked so much and you hardly
hear anything about religion really I
mean do these guys really believe that
they're saving the world from Islam
course they they sort of run with the
ball and gotten out of the field of
course they have you got to remember
that dumb and this is not a new thought
that all the biggest killing in the
history of time was done in the name of
God you can and you can argue either
side of this issue but those who are
pro-life you know in the abortion debate
have no compunction about killing
doctors in the name of God because they
have an opinion in that direction those
who you know fight holy wars through the
ages so mass murder in the name of God
is not a new theory and justifying it as
such is not something that hasn't
happened before
and cleansing one's soul for one's
political beliefs by saying that I'm
doing something that's almost
unthinkable by saying but it's okay I'm
doing it in the name of God is an
age-old bad habit we've had as a
civilization if you can call people who
do things like that that in the white
dress in the back sure
my question was has has it gotten out of
in other words it started in the name of
God but Moscow Said's you know start in
the name of God and sort of end with
them but has this gone beyond if they
sort of become like a bunch of wild
Yahoo's you know I and say I spent a lot
of time with bin Laden I spend an hour
with him on a mountaintop but if you
want to go by a vibe I get from a man I
think that he believed he was doing this
in the name of his God in the name of
his interpretation of that religion and
anybody knows that you know there's
three places you can go and look in a
book and find a page that says it's okay
to kill a page that said it's not okay
to kill one is the Bible the others the
Koran and the only other kind of books
that can tell you it's okay and not okay
do the same thing in the same volume as
a law book so you know it's uh it's it's
not hard to figure out that people seek
out the interpretations that they
believe in okay
miss Donlon runs a tight ship here I'm
gonna let you pick the last question so
this isn't on me okay it's sort of a
two-part question is Nasir still in jail
and if he's not where is he and the
other thing is matter the first one fast
yeah and he ain't going nowhere okay
it was sentenced 20 years on the kahani
business and then life on the conspiracy
to blow up the rest of it okay do you
think it's possible that when they would
try to attack next something that they
would try to how can I say it used
people that would be less suspected for
example when when Israelis were killed
in Cyprus
set of Moslems they sent members of the
IRA who's sort of exchanged tasks with
each other with something like that
would they with the government be
thinking about something like that is
being possible I was then I would give
you mr. John Walker Lindh as one example
I'm uh I'm gonna digress for just ten
seconds to say there was a lot of
discussion and the CIA about how
difficult it would be to penetrate
al-qaeda and that it was something that
they had tried to do and found a
tremendous challenge John Walker Lindh
seemed to just walk in the front door
and said hey what are you guys doing let
me do it with you that raises a lot of
questions about how much we were trying
and the second name is mr. Padilla who
was an American of the Islamic faith who
became radicalized and and sought them
out and was put to work on what's
purported to be a plan to set off a
dirty bomb within the United States and
that information was developed partly in
the camps down in Guantanamo by
questioning suspects there partly by a
very smart CIA operative in a State
Department investigator in the Middle
East who put two and two together and
partly by Abu Zubaydah al Qaeda's chief
recruiter who was in custody who was
shown a picture and said yeah that's the
guy so that's how those things come
together if your question is were they
thinking find people with Western
identities American passports and try to
put them to work for evil the answer was
yeah I just want to say thank you for
being there I think miss Donlan has to
tell you something else right after this
thank you for being here um thank you
for letting me go on and on I urge you
to read the book because now that you
heard what I sound like
Michael Stone wrote most of it so the
rest of it just goes much better than
listening to me
and he's my co-author and did a
tremendous job along with Chris Mitchell
who really did a pretty intimate job of
tracking the hijackers movements leading
up to September 11th but really don't
let the book scare you it doesn't sound
like this speech it's a very good
detective story and there's a lot of
information in there that
I think we all need to know especially
now thanks very very much thank you John
and he's right it is a wonderful book
and a good detective story to make
things easier on all of us what I'm
going to do is I'm going to ask if
anybody is not staying for the book
signing that they leave now and I'm
going to ask that everybody come up form
a line to my right and when you leave
perhaps you could come up Road by row to
make it easier and when you leave leave
to my far right or the middle please
okay come speak to me what the person
was that discussion all that interview
thank you okay
regulator then one at a time John Miller
is co-host of ABC's 20/20 and co-author
of the cell inside the 9/11 plot and why
the FBI and CIA failed to stop it it's
published by Hyperion online at Hyperion
Books calm